and now ladies and gentlemen here are  the starting lineups for the team's  first for the visiting Los Angeles  Clippers from st. John's a 6 7 forward  at number 8  Maurice Heartless from Croatia a  seven-foot-tall Center number 40 of Itza  Sioux box out of Fresno State a 6/8  guard number 13 is Paul George from  Arkansas a 6-1 guard at number 21 and  Patrick Beverley ladies and gentlemen  the head coach of the Los Angeles  Clippers his Doc Rivers please turn your  attention to the video more  [Applause]  how would you describe yourself and what  would you like people to know about you  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  and now with John to the 2019 playoff  [Applause]  -  that'll be aware of the inbounder here  if you're filling  turns the corner  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]